no promises
all right people we are live on the
youtube and the facebook and joining me
today is a sex educator a youtuber and
apparently a very controversial person i
don't get it lacey green welcome to the
reuben report thanks thanks for having
me yeah well i'm looking forward to this
because you are just a bedlam of
controversy oh no i didn't mean to
it's the nature of the work often people
don't mean to and some somehow they get
thrown into it yeah um
but even when when i you know you had an
interesting evolution which we're going
to talk about but just any time i see
anything now of yours on twitter there's
like all this love all this hate all
this confusion yeah and we're gonna
we're gonna talk about all that okay i'm
ready for therapy dave i i really need
it right now it's been a rough few
months just need to unpack all this [ __ ]
yeah and for the record you did say to
me before we started that nothing is off
the record we're gonna just yeah we're
just gonna talk it out yeah all right so
for the people who have no idea who you
are for the for the non-sorta youtube
crowd who the hell is lacey green and
and how did you get here into that chair
yeah uh well i'm a sex educator so you
know
the basic story is i grew up mormon
my family is
was it's less so now but was very
religious and i grew up in a very
religious insulated community and as a
teenager i had a lot of problems around
sexuality stuff with sexual identity
stuff and safer sex not getting pregnant
you know making good decisions trying to
be i was trying to be safe and healthy
and there were no adults in my life that
i could ask about this stuff and i
carried around a lot of sexual shame and
guilt
about who i am and so you know this was
around the time that youtube started
becoming a thing 2005 2006. so in 2007 i
hopped on youtube and just sort of
started ranting to my camera about
mormonism and about you know how messed
up i think it is and um
that sort of grew a following and that
evolved when i went to berkeley to get
my degree i started focusing more on
helping teenagers like myself who are in
these really insulated environments had
no one else to go to who were hopping
online trying to find people and
information you know to deliver that
information to them to be a friend to
them and build a community around that
that was sort of this retreat from these
very uh you know oppressive religious
environments in retrospect does that
seem like a crazy time for you that you
had all these feelings yeah and
it's one thing to have those feelings
and share it with your friend or share
it with you know a therapist or whatever
it is but you jumped on youtube of all
places at the nascent time of youtube it
is sort of serendipitous i suppose it
was kind of a it was a crazy time of my
life but it was also when i look back on
it it's like wow that was really cool
you know i just sort of was using what
was available to me
and i really like what i've built you
know i've been able to build a library
of over 300 videos that explore all
kinds of facets of sexuality and met
young adults all over the world and
really had this amazing experience
connecting with other people and in
doing so really healing from a lot of
the stuff that had hurt me when i was
younger so
i spent
a good couple hours over the last week
catching up on a lot of your stuff from
from the early stuff to the stuff just
from in the last week or something how'd
that go
there's an interesting it's sort of like
a roller coaster but
there's something your comfort level
when talking about the sex stuff yeah
because even though i think because of
the internet people are much better
about talking about this stuff in
general yeah there's still there's still
a lot of awkwardness talking about sex
though it can't be and you talk about
you know just everything from from butt
sex to
give me something else
vaginas lots of vaginas tds chlamydia
herpes i mean all the things that come
up for people in their lives privately
yeah
when you started doing these videos how
long was it before your family found out
what you were doing
um
they it's weird we we've had very few
actual conversations about it to this
day um they knew i was making videos
they knew something was happening
because back when youtube did
spotlighted creators one of my videos
was spotlighted um do you happen to
remember which one it was oh god i'm
embarrassed that i can't remember this
because it's such a like a critical
juncture for me in my youtube channel
yeah yeah but it was i want to say it
was about like
the uh when people would say no homo
it was like a silly little rant about
like no elmo you know how silly it was
that people had to say they were not gay
uh in talking about any sexuality stuff
anyways youtube you know featured this
thing and it blew up and it got over a
million views and that was the first
time i actually started making some
money on youtube and you know i was 18.
you know i was taking out loans for
college and i was like i can pay for
college like i could pay for this year
of college with this video yeah and that
was a pretty big deal that's when my
parents were like
what did you do literally you could pay
for a year of college yeah one video it
was my life how much i made is there
like a rule again well whatever
yeah i was really excited because i was
working two jobs i was babysitting and
nannying and i was working as a waitress
and you know this was a really exciting
thing for me to just have my creative
thing i you know vomited all over the
internet to help me get through school
and you know youtube did help me get
through school it helped me pay for uh
berkeley it helped help me pay for all
my education and accreditation stuff so
yeah what were you studying at the time
uh well when i was in community college
i was trying to figure out what to study
i was originally on track to study
chemistry and when i got into berkeley
it was into their chemistry program um
but then i switched gears a little bit
and went more toward the law because i
wanted to work with sexual assault
survivors yeah so then okay then the
channel starts taking off yes the
channel starts taking off how quickly
did you realize like oh this is gonna be
my life uh
i still haven't really realized that
it is
wow that was thank you for reminding me
this is my life oh god
yeah no i i i don't know i'm just doing
this
it doesn't feel like a thing that i set
out to do it's just like a thing that
i'm doing
it's what i believe in it's what i want
to talk about it's what i care about
that's the bottom line for me yeah so
we're going to talk about some of the
controversies and some of the stuff
that's happened in the last couple of
months but do you oh yeah we're going to
talk about it
but do you remember the first time that
you got sort of pushback against one of
your videos like the first time you
realized that the the mob was out there
oh yeah from the very beginning they're
because i was talking about religion and
you know this is sort of my journey from
mormonism to atheism in the beginning
and i was
really angry about religion i was very
unapologetic i said some kind of
problematic stuff you know i stand by it
though you know i stand by how i feel
about it and if people get offended
that's fine but you know that's how i
feel
and um
yeah i got pushed back from the
religious community first and always
because the sex ed stuff isn't exactly
you know
friendly to a lot of religious stuff and
then i
started getting pushed back when i
started talking about the intersection
of sex and being a woman and sort of my
experience being a bisexual woman and
like the the ways that i have
experienced sexuality um and that sort
of led me to the feminist stuff
and that was a much bigger backlash i
would say against the feminist stuff so
right so you that's sort of where i
became aware of you like you were kind
of in it with
the feminist stuff that sort of then got
looped into a lot of the stuff that i
talked about about the moderator it
became more political in a sense you
know talking about the feminist stuff
and i didn't i had no idea i was wading
into that yeah that's what i was gonna
ask you did you have any sense that that
it was becoming that even though you
were just talking about sort of a sliver
of this through feminism that it really
did represent like this whole other
political thing yeah i mean i was
talking about like being empowered in
the bedroom you know like feeling okay
if you wanna if you're a woman and you
want to have sex or whatever the key is
that it needs to be safe and consensual
[ __ ] shaming is [ __ ] you know you
shouldn't be telling women who they can
sleep with how many people whatever you
know the the bottom line for me in
helping young women is helping them
understand that their body belongs to
them and no one else and then there's
there's the government and there's all
these people there are peers you know
there's their parents there's religion
there's all these people these forces
telling everyone but for me as a as a
young woman you know that lens was how i
experienced it telling me how to
experience sexuality i was like no
uh-uh like that's not how i see it
that's not
it's not empowering yeah you know you're
basically trying to control my body and
control what i do and how i feel
when it has nothing to do with anybody
you know and that's where my feminism
started where do you think that comes
from within you because when i watched
your the old videos even to the new ones
even though you've had an evolution yeah
you always struck me in all these videos
as you you know what you think so even
if that line of thinking has changed you
just always struck me as like confident
this is what i think this is who i am
and even in the early it didn't strike
me as particularly judgmental either
which is what i think a lot of the
people who now fight against feminists
think they're all so judgmental but your
early stuff didn't hugely strike me that
way no it never it was never meant to be
judgmental and you know if anything that
i've said has come off judgmental it's
because i feel like i've been judged you
know it's sort of this like retaliatory
thing and as you get judged are you
kidding me really i know this is a
shocker yeah there's a lot of judgment
that happens um when you're someone who
talks openly about sexuality stuff and
talks openly about religion or anything
that's sort of controversial and taboo
and i was tired of being told not to
talk about it so you know when i look at
my older videos the tone of some of it
is like the tone of an angry young
person and i think a lot of people have
you know young people have a right to be
angry about some of this stuff so
it is what it is you know yeah i don't
want to go too far into the mormon thing
but just i do want to do it a little bit
because one of the things that i find
interesting and i've had several mormons
on the show including glenn beck
one thing i find interesting about
mormonism is it's the one that you're
always allowed to make fun of yeah for
the outside it's one thing for you as a
mormon to do it right because everyone's
allowed to make fun of their own
religion so jews obviously make fun of
judaism christians can make fun of
of christianity et cetera but it seems
like mormonism everyone's allowed to and
not only is everyone allowed to it's
celebrated so the book of mormon is the
biggest hit on broadway that's a good
point when i'm pretty sure there's you
know possibly other books that if they
were to do a thing about it on broadway
yeah
taken so well yeah um
so so to me that almost shows a strength
in mormonism that that the mormon
community has sort of allowed that do
you think maybe i'm misinterpreting that
a little bit strength in that they're
like oh we'll let people make fun of us
yeah i i think there is something
interesting about mormonism in that you
know it's not a proselytizing religion
even though that's kind of their
reputation their whole thing at least
how they talk about that's interesting
because i i thought it was i mean new
york city i used to see those guys with
the latter day saint thing on all the
time walking down the street talking to
people it is it is they have the
missionaries but like the whole thing is
you let people have their faith right
and so
we believe we have the one truth faith
but if other people don't see that or
you know believe that theirs is the one
true faith or whatever like the idea is
you don't impose it on other people
um and so maybe that's where that comes
from but i also think it's acceptable to
make fun of it just because
it's like such a new religion you know
so it's not had all this old history and
mormonism mormons are still trying to
establish their place in the
in the historic in the history of
abrahamic religion yeah so when you
started doing these videos and and your
family is mormon and i got what you said
like they sort of weren't aware has
there ever been any full pushback like
has anyone ever called you and been like
that's the one that's
that's too far
about my videos yeah i don't think they
actually watch the videos and they know
i think they know if they gave me [ __ ]
that i wouldn't care it would just cause
problems it's not going to stop me so
that's part of why we haven't really
talked about it at all i'm not sure if
if any of my family seen any of my
videos my mom told me a couple years ago
that she watched one
and
that's all i remember yeah without going
too deep into the psychology like where
does that kind of put your relationship
with your family because you're doing
something that's so personal to you yeah
it's put a little strain on things
yeah i would say but we have i mean i've
been doing it for 10 years now so
there's been an evolution there yeah and
i
you know i've grown up and i've you know
grown into this a little bit more of a
like i don't really care what anyone
else does or thinks including my own
parents you know i used to be mad at
them but i'm not really mad at them
anymore and i think that makes it easier
to have a relationship and we connect
over things that aren't religion because
you know i'm an adult now so we have a
more adult parent relationship which i
think is easier than the kid-parent
relationships yeah yeah and that's sort
of how things are supposed to evolve
right
yeah exactly and that's how it did and
that's you know things are fine and
great now but there's a little bit of
you know
some pain in the past yeah so all right
so about four months ago or so four
months ago you started
dropping hints that there was maybe
going to be a little change in the type
of things you were talking about or that
you were having your own evolution or i
heard grumblings of it from from people
that we know
although this is the first time we've
met in person but we know a lot of the
same people and i heard some rumors that
maybe lacy's coming around on some of
this stuff that you're always talking
about dave and all that so tell me sort
of what was the moment where you started
realizing that some of the things that
you thought
were not what you thought anymore so i
think this is a common misconception
about this whole situation is that i
didn't think these things before i did i
thought all these things before all the
things that i have said and will
continue to say that are gonna piss some
people off are things that have always
been in my brain and if you look at my
old videos this is what i was saying the
first video i posted if you look at my
old videos where i'm talking about
religion and stuff
it's always been there right but what
happened was
being in this environment where i'm
suddenly
very very hyper aware of making sure
that
the first priority is the people in my
audience the first priority is making
sure that they have a support you know
support and information about sexuality
stuff and that it's empowering i sort of
got
i don't know like moved into this sphere
of people who i i'm not necessarily
politically aligned with like i am but
i'm also not you know like i don't
adhere to this super super lefty stuff
and i've never have i am a liberal
but like
i don't know i feel like there was this
oh a liberal who doesn't fall into all
that lefty stuff well that's the thing
right it's like it's heresy and and i i
felt a lot of pressure a lot of pressure
from
around the world from people to sort of
maintain
this peace and calm and just sort of go
along with it and i did as long as i
could you know with the politics with
the gender politics stuff yeah that's
really what i got swept into right by
being like a sex positive feminist right
and i want to unpack a lot of that stuff
because i'm even watching what's going
on on twitter now with people that
you've been debating or talking about
and there's so many of the words that go
over people's heads i think and confused
oh my god it's a mess
i also think make a certain amount of
people tune out which is something i
want to discuss with you also but all
right so even if you had had some of
these feelings when when you just you
took some time off right you took i did
i took some time off because
um i was preparing to do my doctorate
and uh figure out my grad degree but
also i was really depressed like really
really depressed and was that purely a
function of
realizing what was happening no i've
always dealt with depression really
really intensely and it's always made
doing youtube hard because the youtube
stuff it's a chaotic crazy world as
you're familiar with and for someone
who's really struggling with like the
basics of getting through the day it's
not necessarily something that they can
handle and it certainly wasn't something
that i could handle
um but i got treated in april for the
first time with a treatment that
actually works i've been put on every
antidepressant in the book wow
and none of it helped in fact a lot of
it made me feel really suicidal and i
finally found a doctor in la that really
looked into what was going on and
figured out what the problem was and
fixed it literally overnight
and that was when i was like okay i feel
ready to say to talk about this now i
feel like i can handle it wow so that
was through a psychiatrist so through
something that you were describing just
an md it's just like a doctor but but
through but it was a medication that you
were prescribed uh yeah i mean i don't
want to like go too far into it because
i'm sure nobody cares but it isn't
actually a medication it was i found out
that i have a genetic mutation which
causes my body to process process folate
differently
and to produce prolate differently i
should say so it was about fixing she
basically looked at all the chemical
cycles that make your brain be happy
and put filled in the blanks of the
things that i was missing to make those
chemical reactions happen so now i take
you know a handful of pills every day
and i am so happy and fine and i feel
like myself again it's like magic wait
so it's so it's but it's not a
medication so you're taking like
supplements yeah wow yeah i don't take
any prescription medications for it wow
yeah it's pretty amazing
where do you fall on that i wasn't
planning on asking this but where do you
fall on that whole thing in general
because i think it is related to so many
of the issues that you talk about with
medications yeah with medication in
general i think it can work for people
it did not work for me you know it made
my life a living hell and the fact that
doctors think that's the only way to
treat mental health issues especially
something like depression where there
are it's very complex there's so many
causes now we know more about might be
your you know gut bacteria and all these
things that contribute to it i think
doctors today are overworked don't care
and just throw whatever pill they can at
you and that's what happened to me for
10 years you mean a psychiatrist with a
stapler that says zoloft on it you think
there might be some kind of conflict of
interest there i know i know i mean i
have a lot of things to say about that
it's honestly like what i went through
is so [ __ ] up yeah no nobody who's
dealing with mental health issues should
have to navigate that and yet we do and
then we wonder why we have such a
problem with all these people acting out
behaving in terrible ways it's because
people aren't getting treated you know
they're just being thrown one pill or
another and it's like well you just need
to sit tight for the next five years
until we find the magic pill right and
sometimes there isn't one then you turn
that commercial on and there's a cloud
following that woman and that and then
she needs some other pill to be on top
of that then her legs can't move then
she has then they can move too much then
she's pooping and
it's a lot you need a pill for
everything i mean look like allopathic
medicine has a place in a modern society
it's great it's good science yay but
let's not pretend like that's all all
there is to the picture it's capital and
overage of capitalism into
the the doctor's room and you know that
was essentially what happened to me just
being sold one pill after another when
that wasn't what i needed i'm curious
were you doing talk therapy while you
were doing that yeah i've always done
talk therapy
and but look if it's a imbalance in your
body if it is coming from a physical
imbalance which sometimes it is
sometimes it isn't
talking about it doesn't fix it it can
help you cope but it doesn't really i
mean i feel like there's magic in the
body at this point like it really was
like a switch wow flipped yeah yeah and
so that was you know moving back around
that was kind of
where i started to feel more comfortable
handling the inevitable backlash i knew
this would happen yeah i knew things
would go crazy i knew it would be hard
and people who trusted me and who you
know had supported me would not
understand right away and hopefully they
will understand as time goes on
um
and i knew i had to be able to deal with
that emotionally in a healthy way um
and i finally got to that place yeah so
that's incredible so you really did the
personal work yes i had to prepare
yourself for what was to come which i
think yeah but i think so so many people
especially online people we sort of go
from like one crisis to the next one or
one news cycle to the next thing or you
could have done a really great spit take
right there
i'm going to keep it classy today
but so what you do
yeah there you go
so
that's really incredible though that you
actually like made a point of being like
i'm going to kind of fix my life yes to
go forward in this next thing yeah
because it was literally killing me you
know the the depression and then all the
pressure from all the political
environment all the pressure i was under
like as a
youtube feminist now somehow managed to
become like the face of feminism on
youtube and i was like how did this
happen
i can't handle this i'm a mess i am a
mess and i gotta sort this out otherwise
i gotta quit youtube and that's when i
started telling myself i'm quitting i'm
done i can't do this i can't handle it i
have way too much going on up here
i'm out
but then i got fixed and i was like i'm
back
i mean i really love that because i
think it's so
it's so important for all of us like
whether you have depression or whatever
you have in your life like fixing that
thing which is a work in progress always
and we all myself included are always
trying to improve and sometimes you fail
yourself and whatever but that to move
forward and do something that's real
which i think is what you're doing now
like taking care of that i just think i
think it's great um but just to show
care and feminism
when you see this self-care word thrown
around that's what it means take care of
yourself first then do life oh i thought
itself i thought that was some sort of
vibrator thing self-care i mean that
could be part of it too
many vibrators have been involved in the
self-care process yes yes and by the way
i'm not letting you escape out of
talking about some more sexual stuff but
let's keep going
i'm down so just to show you the way
you've evolved the night of the election
i think when you were still sort of
i guess on the other side of this so to
speak yeah you tweeted something about
the evil white men of america do you
remember sort of what the tweet was how
could i forget that and it reminds me
every day yeah can you i don't i don't
remember what i said i said something
like [ __ ] white america or something
yeah and i stand by that
okay so i think that uh i don't even
know that i was following you at the
time but i knew who you were but i saw
that tweet it went too many and i
retweeted it and i'm sure i wrote some
snarky things so as you're sitting you
deserve snark it was like a stupid tweet
but like i the sentiment behind it i
still feel like we have a racism problem
in america okay so so first off as long
as we're both sitting here can we agree
to put whatever i said in that tweet
yeah i've forgiven everyone for their
sins at this point and you know in
return i expect like some forgiveness
for mine i'm still repenting but i hope
we can all get there so that we can move
on and have good conversations yeah yeah
and a little bit after that i think i
did publicly invite you on the show and
you know things get off lost in the
shuffle
you were going through your own thing
and blah blah blah yeah um
but but i think it's interesting because
even for myself it's like here i saw
someone say something that i obviously
disagreed with but that that that need
to like always attack everybody or like
yeah well it was high tensions time you
know was it that night do you think that
night was high temperature i mean a
little bit you know it was just it was
all right that night was it was tough
for a lot of people so when you saw the
reaction to that type of tweet now i now
i fight against those types of theories
i'm not saying we don't have races in
america of course yeah yeah we're always
going to have bigotry we're always going
to have prejudice some people are just
never going to like gay people some
people are never going to like muslims
or jews or any of those things i would
counterpoint that with saying we could
lower the amount of oh absolutely
it might always be like this low level
but i feel like people are like we're
always going to have this problem
therefore we shouldn't talk about it or
address it because we can't get rid of
it and i would agree that to some extent
like it will never be completely gone
but we can do better
absolutely look as a talk guy i'm all
for talking today i appreciate it yeah i
don't mean that look yes and you're
right maybe we can get it to just be it
whatever its lowest
number could be like yes
let's lower it as much as possible um
but when you saw the reaction to that
type of tweet because i do see a lot of
the people that are in this new space
you're in they they hate the way now
sort of white people are being
like it's just so easy and boring to
attack it
you know there is a time and a place for
that sort of analysis but it isn't the
time and the place that it's often used
online i think including that tweet yeah
um that was the wrong way of expressing
my sentiments but look i was angry and
to be honest i was pretty drunk yeah
so
you ever think about that what do you do
i'm glad you said that though because
it's so funny like anyone that's a
public person like we're all flawed
characters we all get drunk sometimes or
might open up twitter
and like at any moment you could just
unleash the gates of hell on yourself
that's exactly what happened yeah yeah
and without even realizing like i don't
even remember tweeting that you know
that's just funny
you know it's funny too don't drink kids
that's the moral of this story
there's a lot of boobs behind you by the
way
or don't drink and tweet let's put it
that way that keep the tweeter closed
you should put that on a shirt yeah
but it's funny because i in my in my old
days when i was on
that portion of the left or when i saw
things through that lens or i was a
progressive or whatever it was there are
tweets of mine saying that same kind of
thing about old white men yeah and i
haven't deleted them and people will
occasionally grab one of something i
said five years ago and go ah you see
reuben we got you yeah and i'm like no
you you didn't get me yeah you're
actually showing that
what that i've evolved which is what
i've said totally instantly totally but
they want to get you right yeah they do
my personal philosophy is there needs to
be like an opinions expiration date like
more than a year ago you cannot
reasonably assume that i think the same
exact thing or would say or you know
discuss it the same exact way doesn't
that make you a flip-flopper lisa
open-minded learning growing human being
and that's something we should encourage
you know not like look at you you
changed
you you grew and learned things you
terrible person you know it's just like
what i mean
isn't that funny that so much of that
comes from the so-called tolerant people
like yes i mean that's the thicker way
you're dealing with but wait
so before we fully get there so you you
do this work internally for yourself
which is obviously incredible you take
some time off which i'm sure cost you
money to do because your videos make
money so like you really did something
important for you
um were you privately discussing with
friends what you were gonna do because i
was tipped off by by one person who
doesn't need to be named right now
no who's
but you'll have no problem with it
because it was done it was done the way
it's supposed to be done
right it was basically just like keep an
eye on her like like keep an eye on like
someone that's kind of doing in an
interesting spot right now okay that's
it it was nothing all right yeah it was
nothing bad whatsoever i made that sound
much more
shame yeah i mean i have a lot of
paranoia after all my friends like
posted things about me during this yeah
and posted personal information about me
yeah all right so and yeah you've been
doxxed and yeah it's just been crazy now
i like feel very it's kind of changed my
life in the sense that i'm like who can
i really talk to about these things that
i'm not ready to just go full out public
with yet you know i'm still a human and
i need to process these things yeah um
but yeah your question was well
basically so you do the work for
yourself you take the time off it costs
you money like you actually did what you
had to do for yourself yeah now get me
to
that first video that you did right yeah
so i've been talking to people for a
long time um and anybody who's a good
friend of mine knows that i've always
thought this stuff is [ __ ] for a
long time like i meant to them and have
had a lot of really bizarre experiences
in feminist spaces that were just a lot
to process my friends you know they have
been really supportive and like yeah
this is weird i don't know i don't know
can you give me like a really solid
example of that well like in the video i
talked about how people have tried to um
physically intimidate me in person
people who are feminists who i agree
with on stuff you know maybe not 100 but
like 90 maybe i don't know
and people who try to gang up on me who
threatened to rape me who threatened to
you know i had this group of people at a
it was like a group of trans activists
folks who threatened to punch me in the
face out when i was in a parking lot and
i'm just like oh
that's my brain what
i like can't what is why what did i do
yeah even though from everything i've
seen of yours i've never seen even the
slightest amount of transphobia
i am
all here for people who are trans like
seriously i do not give a [ __ ] i support
them i think society treats trans people
like [ __ ] you know and i'm in that fight
with them and always have been i've
advocated you know at the state and
federal government level for trans
rights and you know taught
trans-inclusive sex ed the entire time i
mean it's just it's weird so that th
those types of things
what was it that they were upset with
you about like in that specific instance
in that specific instance they and can
people continue to talk about a video
that i made in the earlier days of
youtube where i made a video to chris
crocker do you know who that is yeah i
interviewed my my old yeah so i'm a big
fan of chris yeah and always had them
like back in the league brittany alone
yes or whatever because i just he was
one of the first
he was one of the first sort of
he was made by the internet and also the
first great victim of the internet in a
way yeah his story is super fascinating
but he's also sort of this like gender
bending you know sexuality just sort of
a fluid interesting person around that
stuff and i found that empowering you
know and so i was really big fan and i
made this video this fan video to him
and at the time chris had called himself
the t-word that's how he referred to
himself and so i used that word in the
video in a fan video you know wait the t
word so he called himself trans oh wait
am i not did i just miss something
people are gonna yell at me
yeah well you're just quoting something
that someone said i know but people get
really mad but whisper it a little
louder they're gonna try to slit my
throat
i'll say it and i'll you know what i'll
take the heat on this one okay
you called chris [ __ ] because that's
the word he was using about himself i
said he's my favorite he's okay so you
said that chris was your favorite [ __ ]
a word that he was using
to describe himself it's so silly i feel
so silly it's so dumb
you feel the need to whisper i know but
look i have been violently threatened
you have to understand like i have been
violently threatened yeah many times
over this so
so what were they angry so did they i
mean i know so much of this is why it's
it's so about feelings and not about
facts yeah
so you get these they're angry you
because you've now used this word even
though you've shown
this is sort of like bill maher using
the n word even though no one in their
right mind would think he's a racist
and having to pay the price for that um
yeah it's more about the word like it's
all about the language you know um and i
was 17. you know and i regret it but at
the same time it's like oh my god how
many times do i have to be sacrificed at
the altar for this
and um
yeah i've had a lot of experiences like
that just moving through the feminist
world and just being shown no mercy
nobody ever wants to assume that you are
just a person who means well you know
you always mean the worst it's always
that you're a bigot you know you are
just a racist you are just a transphobe
that's who you are and we hate you for
it and that's kind of been my experience
moving through this world even though my
whole thing is like i don't think people
should hate people because of
their skin color or their sex or their
gender identity or whatever so there's
just a lot of dissonance
and it's put me in a really weird place
so even though you said a couple times
that you you always sort of had these
feelings was there ever a moment for you
that you really were in it like that
like did you ever because it becomes you
can almost become drunk with power in a
way when these people are going you know
when they're backing you i know but they
never backed me and i've never thought
that behavior was okay you know if i've
ever said anything that came off that
way it was purely accidental or being
pressured to talk about it that way
because otherwise i would be you know on
the firing line
but i've never
i've never condoned the sjw stuff and
i've never even though i've said and
done a few things that are regrettable
you know i don't feel that on the whole
my work embodies any of that i think it
is very different than that um and
i'm very opposed to it i think it's
really toxic and destructive and
very hypocritical
so you do this video
you start saying some of this stuff and
really what you more than anything else
the takeaway from the video is i want to
talk to people that's literally all the
video says yeah i mean that and i think
that thing like i want to talk to people
because i think things have gotten a
little out of control in the feminist
sphere it's super pro censorship
like overtly pro like we are going to
campaign to get you censored you know
and i actually had a friend of mine a
good friend of mine this is actually
i'm still processing it a good friend of
mine who
you know is campaigning after i came out
with this stuff a good feminist friend
of mine we had planned to go travel
together and we've been we've traveled a
lot together already who decided to who
wanted to make a petition you know to
shut my channel down or
i don't even remember exactly what it
was but it was just like what the hell
like this this is someone i'm pretty
good i'm pretty good friends with like
it's very overtly we don't like the the
goal is to silence
no other opinions should be heard
because it's oppressive i'm oppressive
now so even though you intellectually
knew that that thing existed
were you shocked when it became that
personal because i had the exact same
thing even though i for me it wasn't
talking about feminism but when i
started talking about what i saw wrong
with the left and the the speech stuff
and the your friend
i lost i lost a ton of friends uh
co-workers of mine
stopped talking to me but but friends i
mean people some people that i had that
were invited to my wedding
uh that's yeah
that's really messed up yeah i mean
same for me so when you would have when
you would have those conversations so
i'll just give you one anecdotal thing
for myself and maybe you have one for
you is one there was one person who was
was i was incredibly close to incredibly
close to and um
they started telling me privately on
text and what a bigot i am and blah blah
blah and i kept saying can you show me
evidence of anything that i've said is
bigoted you know me really well we've
you know been to my house a thousand
times for dinner we've gone through
personal stuff and cried together and
all this stuff
and i couldn't get one example of
anything it's just no no you're a bigot
you're a bigot you're a bigot
so when your friend you know then starts
doing this protest against you i mean
it's not just friend friends yeah so
were you able to make headway with any
of them or did it all just like um melt
at the same time
and the reason i'm asking you this so
specifically is because i i'm sure you
do too but i get a ton of email about
this that from my audience when they
start talking about this stuff or they
share clips or whatever but suddenly
friends are blocking them or defending
them and all that stuff oh god
what has this world come to yeah
priorities misplaced you know you can't
even have friendship anymore yeah i mean
for me
i have lost a lot of friends um
people who i have let into my home who
you know i've made dinner for many times
who again you know we've had the moments
we've laughed we've cried who turned on
me in a you know in a heartbeat um the
moment i said that i was against
censorship which is very strange
um and it's been really hard because
these are it's been like well i feel
kind of lost now
my community has
turned on me in a sense um but maybe
they were never my community to begin
with like what i said before i sort of
just by proximity and sort of being
nudged in this direction
have um
you know
met all these people and built these
relationships and
a lot of those relationships i felt like
were kind of fake to begin with like you
always feel like you're being judged um
that's kind of what i feel like hanging
out with people who are super super
sjw feminist types it's like you can't
relax you can't tell a joke you're like
worried that everyone's going to be
offended all the time it's just like a
very oh like can we just calm down just
on that like hairpin of like i might say
something wrong accidentally and then
it's all over like that's not a fun way
to have a friendship no and it's so easy
to say something wrong like you like it
it's such a bizarre arbitrary high bar
and it's it's not a good precedent for
friendships and relationships and i
never liked it you know i never felt
connected to those people there was
maybe only one
or two people that i really felt like we
had a connection who turned on me
publicly
um but then like all these people that
are internet friends of mine who i've
never met in person or anything but who
you know we share each other's work we
talk online whatever also turned on me
so it's been sort of this ripple effect
as
people just sort of
you know cast me out of the club and
that's been
very revealing you know if you if this
is what gets you thrown out then [ __ ]
you throw me out i don't give a [ __ ]
it's so interesting because just sit you
know just getting to know you in this
half hour or whatever it's like you you
did this once already in life you did
this when you were 16 or 17. bingo yeah
and it's just a replay for me it's
literally the same exact thing it's like
you have this community that is
organized around moral principles and
you feel really repressed and shamed and
restricted whenever you have a you
commit a thought crime and you have to
confess and you have to apologize when
you make a mistake but your apology is
never really good enough you always are
deep down an original sinner yeah you
know and you have to be cast out you're
going to be excommunicated if you make
too many mistakes it's the same exact
thing and so many people
so many of them hate religion but
they'll give you original sin which is
which is a whole a whole other thing
it's just moral systems yeah they all
work the same way right whether they're
moral whether they're religious or
secular or
that is a
on another note like that's a big
question that i'm trying to figure out
is how do we create moral systems for
humans without devolving into this trash
like how do we encourage people to
encourage people to be good people yeah
without
all this because it seems to come with
the territory in my experience yeah so
okay so you lost friends your audience
had all sorts of issues dealing with new
lacie yeah all of this stuff but so
let's get away from the band for a
second let's talk about the new
community that you've been welcomed into
yeah because now you're in the community
that on the online side of it the
youtube side of it
it's mostly the people that i love like
like this great community and i saw you
were you were at vidcon with a lot of
these people yeah
and had a great time and and got to
suddenly meet people that were your
enemies in a certain respect
at some level i never saw them as my
enemies only the ones that made really
terrible videos about me yeah so it
wasn't most of them so let's talk about
one person in particular because i think
something really beautiful happened
which is uh carl benjamin sargon of
akkad yeah i had him here live the the
day that he went to vidcon so i think i
think maybe i think maybe you met him
that night perhaps
and i had known that he had done some
videos about you and i said something to
him
uh off camera about um
something like oh are you gonna see
lacey i guess she probably doesn't like
you like something like that
and he said to me i kid you not he was
like he was like i don't know why she
wouldn't like me like i it's not
personal
and he really meant it like i didn't
sense he was like it is personal okay so
so i'm not trying to start [ __ ] because
i'm really not but but you guys then met
yeah and something kind of good came out
of it well i went into it prepared to
forgive him even though i would say you
know carl has been the root of a lot of
the pain from the anti-side for me not
just because he goes around claiming
things like i lied about being sexually
assaulted you know that really
that's a really shitty thing to do but
also because when i was getting bomb and
shooting threats at the schools that i
was visiting
we had like traced where some of these
people were coming from and they were
big fans of carl
so you know
there was just sort of this proxima
proximal connection to him as well with
a lot of the online harassment and the
real world threats that i was getting
were mostly coming from
his little corner of the internet
and um
you know i
have had a lot of
trouble with carl's stuff with the way
that he's talked about me with the way
that he has
portrayed me to people you know
sort of lying about things distorting
things i've said
um
but my
in my mind like there's a context
you know i think that
i don't know i'm still making sense of
it but i
don't i don't want to hold on to any of
that you know and i know that people
have been telling me like chris had been
telling me even when this all started i
was like i'm absolutely not forgiving
carl i just can't i can't do it
um but after talking to people and
you know
i actually talked to carl first online i
reached out and i was terrified
and i did it and it was fine so this is
before vidcon is it before yeah this is
after the first video but before vidcon
and
i just told myself you know what i gotta
i gotta move past this like i'm sure
there's a lot of junk and all this kind
of garbage that has contextualized these
experiences and i just want to move on
from it
and that's why i decided to forgive him
but
um and i want to talk to him you know i
want to talk to him about the things
that he has criticized the ideas
for me it's not the criticizing ideas
criticize my ideas all day long like
let's let's talk about it you know but
don't make it personal don't make it
about
me being sexually violated like that's
not okay you know that's crossing a line
and that's what i had to forgive was the
crossing the line
and
you know i've forgiven people for much
worse in my life yeah so you guys met so
you met yeah and i think it's important
because
everyone's fighting with everyone all
day especially online people non-stop
tearing each other apart we we've both
now given examples how how this also
leaks into real life friendships and all
that so you finally get face to face now
here's a guy who i really like him and
you know i like a lot of business
i honestly can't say that i that i ever
watched one of his videos about you i
truly have no recollection of that but a
lot of the stuff that he talks about
that i care about about classical
liberalism and all that we're fully on
board and as i said i like him and i had
drinks with him that night and
everything else okay so you finally meet
him and it's very different when you're
snarking at someone through a youtube
video versus when you actually are
looking them in the eye can you just
tell me what that felt like for you it
was it was sort of a a surreal moment
because we had we all of us all the
antis or the skeptics or critics or
whatever you want to call them had come
up to l.a some generally decent people
generally
the gdps i think there's a lot of people
out i'm referring to the specific genre
of content online right like all these
people make this type of videos online
had come up and were going out for a
night you know in la and so i joined
them and
i just sort of ran into carl
on a street corner as we were moving our
party elsewhere
and that was the first time that i had
met him
and we just sort of stared at each other
and you know he
held out his hand to shake hands and i
was like wait you're not gonna give me a
hug after all the [ __ ] you put me
through i think you owe me a hug
um and
he hugged me he's a really big guy you
know i'm kind of a shorty he's just like
this big teddy bear
he hugged me and he just sort of you
know leans down to my ear and says i'm
really sorry you know i had no idea what
i was doing i regret it and you know
we can spar out our differences but i
had no idea the pain that i had caused
you
and
that to me was just like earth
shattering because i had dealt with so
much [ __ ] you know
and to be there and to be on the street
corner
you know just being hugged by this
person who i had been terrified of
and to realize
okay it's not so scary
he's
perfectly fine person and everything's
going to be okay
was really
i will never forget that moment yeah for
the rest of my life yeah and then you
shot i think two videos on it right you
put up two i just shot like some little
parts
because
we took a picture
and when he posted it online people lost
their minds
and i was like oh here we go like i
can't even have this one precious moment
to heal from some of my own
[ __ ] you know
the internet has to weigh in and give
their opinion on how i should deal with
how i've been harassed right and this is
very you think you have some right to
tell the internet how you feel about
what's happening to you
it's just crazy because like in this
community like in the leftist stuff the
whole idea is we let people handle their
their problems however they like there's
no right way to
deal with being harassed or whatever
like that's a feminist mantra like you
do you right should be the feminist
right it should be that's my feminist
mantra yeah you do your thing i'll be
here for you you know just don't hurt
people um but no for me to deal with
what i had dealt with in my life and
then to forgive him other people i think
what happened other people took that as
oh well now i have to
give up my grudge or whatever i have to
forgive him for which is great
actually if you can challenge people
right if you can't find but like that's
not my idea my goal isn't to be like
okay everybody hug
you know like i want to because that's
what feels good and right to me
forgiveness and that's what the video is
about forgiveness for me is how i move
through my life because people make
mistakes people learn and grow they do
and say stupid [ __ ] all the time myself
included like pretty much non-stop so if
people can't forgive me you know how can
i ever forgive myself for one thing but
also how can we move through this world
how i don't understand
and you know that's why i didn't a big
part of why i did it and
other people see it differently and
that's fine but i don't think it's any
of their business yeah like it really
has nothing to do with anybody else but
me and carl
that's it so on the broader side of that
were you shocked how much love and
support you got from these people yes
so on the positive side
yes i mean i have made so many new
friends that are just really cool really
smart interesting people
you know we don't necessarily agree 100
i'd say like a lot of us we agree maybe
like 70 as opposed to 90. i'm perfectly
okay with that i don't even care if we
agree zero percent well we have to have
some
very basic agreements i would say but
you know it's so much my world has
changed not just like
healing from the depression stuff but
and healing from like letting go of my
pain around this stuff but also now
realizing
that there is a place that i can be
happy people that i really enjoy that
are hilarious and laughing more than i
like ever have like in the last five
years
they're so funny
i just
i'm so happy with these with this
community it really is a beautiful
community i love that and it's like it's
like raiding out radiating out of you i
can tell let's talk about one of those
people in particular because you
mentioned chris before yeah you are now
dating chris raygun of the internet
and chris uh
he's in the other room right now so this
makes it makes it a little awkward i
suppose
but but i love what chris does he he's
hilarious he's incredibly talented and
funny and smart he gets it politically i
think from at least the way i think
getting it yeah has value and all that i
agree on most things yeah
um
how is it dating a another youtuber
you're public people dating people want
to know things about you i know that's
my kind of weird it's
sort of silly and fun i don't know it
adds a different dimension to this
relationship that i don't have with
others that i haven't had in the past
um because i haven't really ever well i
dated one youtuber when i was a teenager
but you know it was not nearly as public
as as this has been but it's really fun
like i i really enjoy it i love being
able to have sort of to share this
digital sphere together um i feel like
that's something that adds a lot of
value to my life into our relationship
you know we have our own thing but then
we can also have this sort of fun
public-facing
um relationship too which is i don't
know it's just fun yeah all right cool
um all right so i want to talk to you
about a couple sex things and then we're
going to do an hour of q a we already
have like a gajillion questions so i've
tried to i've tried to do all the broad
stuff with you here because i wanted
people to really understand your story
sure and then i'm going to let the
audience do like the specific things
okay but a couple things on on sex
because i watch so many of your videos
and uh you are a sexpert of uh of some
sort i mean
within reason so that's
that's why i wanted to ask it that way
yeah i want for you personally as
someone that talks about all these
things and how to pleasure a man how to
pleasure a woman
you know different body parts and what
people like and all that stuff do you
feel undue pressure when you're
having sex
um
because i thought that a couple of times
in your videos like man this girl knows
everything about sexy
i can get around pretty well i would say
because but i'm like the thing is people
assume oh god she must be like a total
freak or something
and like sometimes but for the most part
yeah you gotta live you know i feel
comfortable with my sexuality and i know
like the mechanics i know i'm like a
textbook person right you know there's a
difference between the textbook and the
real life experiences the textbook helps
me navigate the real life experiences
but i'm just a normal person you know
just like like everyone else and
not to get to tmi but like with with
people i've been with in the past there
is sort of this like weight
on the relationship right that's like oh
you teach sex ed to millions of people
right like what are you gonna bust out
tonight you know like okay okay we did
that last night like you have to have
this like endless book of magic tricks
no no no no i mean it's just normal
i don't know i don't know i've never sat
in on someone else's bedroom but i would
say that like
pretty
normal sexual whatever i'm just
comfortable talking about it yeah all
right let's talk about gender and gender
identity and how many genders there are
all this stuff and that that so we're
going to do that for let's say 10
minutes or so and then we'll jump into
the q a okay but the reason i want to
talk about it is because first off i
think a ton of it is hugely confusing i
think a certain amount of people are
making it intentionally i know what is
going on with that and and when i've
seen even it's actually
it's not one of the issues that i am
that interested in i i want people to be
respected and validated and all those
things but it's not like one of my like
key issues so when i've seen
some of the fights that go on and some
of the conversations that go on even
that you're having on twitter or
wherever
my general feeling is when people get so
in the weeds about how you should refer
to this person you have to say this
about this person or watch it i think
it's tuning more people out to the
legitimate issues than making people
care about them because i feel it for
myself i see so much fighting about it
that i'm like
why would i even want to touch this
using it
i want to respect trans people i want to
resp i want to respect everybody it's
basic yeah this stuff is not that
complicated you know there's when you
get into the philosophical elements of
like what is gender like what are all
the elements of gender like if you
really want to go deep yes it's
complicated but the problem is that like
the discourse has forced everyone to go
deep in order to just be like a
basically educated decent human being
right and for me in my sex ed it's
always been about here's the basic stuff
like we don't need to get too crazy all
right here's what you need to know okay
so what are the things you need to know
gender about the gender stuff yeah like
let's just do some gender one-on-one
stuff you know some people think of man
and woman differently you know people
think of man and woman differently and
they relate to their sex differently you
know they relate they people think of
their sex trans people think of their
sex very differently than you know you
and i as cisgender as a term for people
who don't have any sort of sex
uh disconnect um you know they think
about the dna you can be a cisgendered
heterosexual or bisexual woman you can
be a cisgendered
gay man yeah meaning that you're just
you believe that you are of the you're
comfortable calling yourself a man yeah
you have a penis you're a man the end
okay some people don't feel that way you
know have a penis i'm a man
some people have a penis and they're a
woman some people have a vagina and
they're a man and that's just how they
experience it and that's the way it is
so respect it the end you know it
doesn't need to be like this big
so but for the people that don't
understand that so how can someone have
a vagina and be a man well it with trans
folks specifically i'll talk about
gender dysphoria because i think that's
actually like the defining one of the
defining elements here that is easiest
to understand okay you know gender
dysphoria sex dysphoria is where people
are in their own body and they are
experiencing their genitals right and
they feel i don't have this so i'm just
sort of quoting from what people have
told me right don't get mad at me
internet all right
but go ahead anyway you know they feel
um you know deep discomfort with their
genitals and this is a real thing it is
a mental health issue that people
struggle with
and it needs to be treated by a
psychologist and possibly by a
psychiatrist and that is just a
condition that some people have and so
for that the treatment you know in that
circumstance is for someone to
transition their sex to feel more
comfortable in their own body right to
feel like the world their gender and the
world around them matches how they see
themselves
and they can transition their body they
can that's the medical transition they
can transition socially which is where
they're like okay i'm going to be i'm
going to call myself a man or a woman
now right and i'm going to change my
name and then there's the legal
transition where you change your
driver's license all these things right
so there are different ways to help
people move through the world in a way
that's more comfortable for them and um
you know a lot of people get all freaked
out about it and i think the whole like
you can you need to sleep with with
people who have genitals different than
what you prefer
it flames that paranoia it's like whoa
whoa whoa it's fine until you know you
told me who i need to sleep with yeah
yeah wait let's pause on that because i
want people to understand that so there
is this sort of contingent of people
who think that even if you're okay with
trans people yeah that you should still
be okay
with sleeping with someone who doesn't
have the genitals you like otherwise
that in and of itself shows some sort of
bigotry did i get that right that is
correct yes that is right and that's
you're exactly right that's where the
average person that wants to be a good
inclusive person and and that's where
they start going because now it's not
about the other person now it's about me
like and not only is it about what
you're telling me to do it's about what
you're saying about who i am that i am a
bad person for having different sexual
preferences and this comes back to the
shame right it comes back to the sexual
shame and like the whole the whole goal
in like the gender and sex positive
movements is that we don't shame people
you know we don't make people feel bad
even if their preferences are you know
problematic you know
there are some applications of that like
the more extreme stuff like the
pedophilia and the bestiality which are
different contexts but even you know
stuff that is like oh you know you're
you are transphobic or you are you know
a little bit sexist or whatever like
that kind of stuff
the solution isn't to shame them
solution isn't to make them feel like
their sexual preferences are bad because
sexual preferences aren't something you
just choose in your head you know
they're a way you feel and people feel
like that's sort of outside of their
control and it is you know so telling
them you need to control this otherwise
you're a bad
person when we're talking about safe and
consensual sex
is an incredibly problematic message to
send to people for me as a as a sex
educator who wants people to feel
comfortable and okay what do you think
about just the suffix phobia we
everything now is a phobia yeah and i
and i think that it's done a major
disservice i don't think every person
even right now in 2017 as i tell you
this as a married gay man i don't think
that every person in america a christian
conservative who lives in the middle of
the country that isn't okay with gay
marriage yet and maybe never will be i
don't think that inherently makes them a
homophobe i would like to show them that
gay people are like everyone else yeah i
wish that they would
be a little more open-minded or
something but this word phobia or
transphobia that you fear them yeah i
feel like it's it's not the right word
it's actually creating more
craziness around it what do you think a
better word would be
if you have one
i don't know well i prefer i prefer no
word i'd prefer an explanation of their
ideas
and this is where we all get lost in
labels and all that kind of stuff
language right but i think when you put
the phobia thing on it i think it just
it pushes those people the other way and
i know look i mean i think every gay
person knows this when you come out to
people even your friends that maybe were
a little weird about gay people or
whatever that's how you change them yeah
they simmer down usually not by
screaming at them right not always and
some people are going to do what what
people did to you when you came out in
this new
sort of thinking yeah they're gonna
they're gonna abandon you it's just how
it is yeah i mean i would agree with you
that like
i don't necessarily agree that it's not
a fear because i think a lot of these
things stem from fear a lot of our you
know like just an irrational fear which
is actually
like a tribalist sort of fear um i think
is what a lot of this com some of it
comes down to
but um you know with in terms of
the problem for me is calling you a
homophobe or a transphobe or you know
sort of using this as a
shaming device instead of a device to
help people understand
you know how their perception has been
shaped so you know if i'm dealing with a
guy who's you know talking to me in a
pretty sexist way which happens you know
he's like staring at my boobs he's like
you know treating me in this way that
i'm like a piece of meat that he's gonna
try to like round up and take home you
know it's like oh my god give me a break
right i'm not gonna be like well you're
a sexist
that's not even though i'm like this is
sexist right right that's not gonna like
help him understand why this approach
that he's taking to talking to me at
this bar is is not working right i'm
gonna say well you know right now i feel
like you're
my experience of this situation right
now is this this and this and this is
why i don't think it's like a good thing
if i was gonna sit down and explain that
to him at a bar i wouldn't right right
generally he's not gonna stick around
but if it's like a guy friend of mine
right and he's he's behaving in this way
that's like you know kind of putting
women off or being disrespectful i'm
gonna explain why it's disrespectful and
you know have a conversation about it
and hopefully try to understand where
he's coming from so that you know we can
have a good productive exchange to sort
of
chill out that behavior if indeed that
is a problematic behavior right and he
could dispute my claim that it's sexist
or whatever
um but that to me is the approach you
know the approach is not to name call
and these terms sexist racist homophobic
these have meanings right and they have
a place they have a time but i think
they should be applied more to systems
like referring to system stuff
like this law that says um gay people
can't get married is homophobic or
whatever as opposed to this individual
person is uncomfortable about blah blah
and they are homophobic right do you
know what i'm saying right or this
person likes the genitals of the
opposite sex because that's what he's
attracted to but somehow he's
but that's not even transphobic in my
opinion see then there's like the usage
of the words where it's not even right
yeah well i don't see how that's
transphobic well like yeah when when
people say oh you need to sleep with
someone who has genitals that are
different than you prefer
um i and if you don't you're transphobic
i would say that's not transphobic yeah
i would say that and in fact you're
homophobic
singing you see what you're doing there
you see what you do got to play the game
yeah i can use the game against them
well isn't that the interesting thing
it's very easy to use their own games
against them you know i don't
you know i try not to use any of my
identity stuff in that way yeah i i try
not to either but but every now and
again they are because their stuff is so
sort of base level you can use it
against them pretty effectively yeah
even though it's not the it's not what i
would prefer to play in really yeah
yeah um all right so one other thing and
then we'll take a quick break and then
we'll do the the q a as you're talking
about this i'm curious i don't know that
i've seen you do anything on the men's
rights stuff but do you do you think or
first off have you done anything really
on the not on like the men's rights
movement per se but i have done stuff
about men's rights particularly around
sexuality stuff like um male sexual
assault and circumcision yeah are the
two issues that i've tackled because
that's in my sex ed sphere
not necessarily you know the stuff that
is
brought more broadly men's rights yeah
so on the on the broader side though
yeah do you think like a lot of this
does i see i get emails from people that
you know it's usually from from straight
men just saying that all of this stuff
is
pushing them the other way yeah
you do i assume you see you yeah i think
people are
uh understandably alienated
if i'm alienated like come on right
right that's not a good sign if i'm
being alienated by this stuff we got a
problem because i'm not very easily
alienated by these types of things
did we hit all the major points in this
first hour because we still got another
hour now and it's
it's going to be a little faster and
there's going to be a lot of very
pointed questions okay did we hit all
the broad stuff i think so feel good i
feel good you want a 30 second break yes
all right we're going to take a 30
second break and then we're going to be
taking questions on patreon we've got
like 100 sitting there already uh we're
also going to be doing the super chat
thing i think you guys know how to do
that right here on the youtube chat and
we'll try to maybe jump in on a couple
questions on facebook and all that good
stuff uh so give us uh like a minute or
two and uh we'll see if lacie wants to
do a shot or something in between
then we'll go from there all right we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we are back we're live on
uh youtube and on facebook the questions
are rolling in already so we're doing
the super chat thing on uh on youtube if
you're on there and we're doing uh
patreon questions over here we've got a
zillion good ones for you
let's start with this super chat first
have you ever read 1984 and do you
relate with your recent stress related
to what's going on i read 1984 in high
school
i read it around 84. oh did you oh gee
um no i don't really remember it very
well so
so i think the basic thrust of it being
like do you relate to just sort of the
orwellian like thought police and just
that yeah yeah i mean to some
degree yes
the thought policing for sure
um i think that there's too much like
telling people what to think and shaming
them for thinking things instead of sort
of if you think what someone
says or does or thinks is wrong
you should talk about that and not just
i don't know come bring the band hammer
down you shouldn't just destroy people
relentlessly all right fair enough uh
all right patreon
oh what did you think of dave rubin
before you reached across the aisle i've
always been you know well i only
discovered yourself like a few months
ago but i've always enjoyed it like i
don't think that you do anything that's
particular
you mean i'm not an alt-right neo-nazi
white supremacist something about you is
gay hating these people i mean you're
sort of in the same boat as me you know
it's just the yeah well that's why your
your adventure and when you when you
started coming out so to speak i was
like i've got to talk to her because i
was like because because the thing that
you're going through now
that i've been through and it never
stops really like there's no moment
where you're like oh it's over and now
we're clean and clear
but so many people are going through
this in their own lives that's true
that are not public people or or
whatever it is that we are yeah okay but
they're like slandering you very
publicly is the problem anyways yeah
yeah yeah what are you gonna do all
right super chat please ask lacey about
whether she thinks prescribing children
puberty blocking drugs that will affect
them for the rest of their lives is a
good idea
um i
i don't necessarily want to like state
my stance on this right now just because
i have very complicated thoughts about
it okay i will say i am critical
of that critical of giving them giving
kids puberty blockers yeah okay
uh quick uh super chat what do you
recommend to help fix the current state
of online discourse and make it more
civil i think we've done all right for
an hour here
we have done all right yeah we cursed
each other relentlessly that's true we
got it all out of our system first
that's why we could do this yeah no i
think um
i think one of the main things that
people need to do is really everyone
even people who think they're committed
to the dialogue need to really be
checking themselves to make sure they're
actually behaving in ways that promote
dialogue and be open-minded i mean
that's really what it comes down to you
can have your own opinions and you can
be very passionate about them too but
you can also respect that there are
other opinions you know very a person
might have an opposite opinion and be
very passionate about that as well we
should try to understand that i think a
commitment to listening a commitment to
questioning our own beliefs
a commitment to you know hearing other
people's
perspectives and really deeply
considering them and also making sure
you fully understand your own opinions
as well
all of those things would promote
dialogue
get rid of the personal attacks i don't
like that [ __ ] it's just like why all it
does is make people mad i'm gonna have
my guys cut that one minute and those
are going to be lacy's rules for for
fixing the universe okay
um
we've sort of discussed this one a
little bit but uh patreon why do there
have to be two sides what about the
center so i've been talking about this
new center thing for a while and i think
it has a really wide net and sometimes
you're going to get caught with some
people that you strongly disagree on
some things but i think if we can get
the basics of people that want to live
in a logical decent tolerant society
that we've got a pretty good center yeah
i think you know the center is big
you know people sometimes think of the
center as like this these wishy-washy
people who just don't know what they
think but to me you know the center is
people who are not ideologues they're
people who are willing to change their
mind about things and don't necessarily
see things in black and white and i
think that's a good thing yeah i'm with
you on that uh lacey will you do an
appearance at my hometown of uh
coxson hole honduras i hope i'm
pronouncing that right
[Laughter]
you just got trolled maybe it's a real
place who knows
[ __ ] in hole
there's this
[ __ ]
i mean there's a place called lake
titicaca so you never know well i think
that's
no lord i mean that's literally i just
got i just got mo sis lacked from the
simpsons um
is there an alcoholic here okay
uh how is your this is from patreon how
has your work impacted your dating life
are you guys intimidated thrilled what
are the costs and benefits of being
outspoken on the subjects that you deal
with that's kind of two two different
questions there but let's just focus on
the dating points how it's affected my
dating life well kind of like what we
were talking about earlier where people
come in with all these assumptions about
you being this freak in the sheet yeah
um
and yeah i think it's also made it
difficult because
well in la there's a lot of people who
are just trying to climb a social ladder
and they will use their dating life to
do that so there's all this like weird
fakeness that you have to deal with as a
youtuber um but the sex ed stuff i would
say for the most part beside this i
think a lot of
you know the people that i've dated all
having have told me they had anxiety at
the beginning
because of this
like literally everyone i've
ever dated including chris that's funny
so people come in potentially with no
anxiety start dating lazy anxiety well
just like i had a little bit of anxiety
about dating a sex educator
which is fine but i think it becomes
pretty clear right away that there's no
need to be freaked out when they get to
the to your bedroom do they immediately
look at the the night table and like
what is in there like you know what i
show them like what about take it out
like what am i getting myself involved
in like there's a lot of stuff in there
i don't know if you have like a big
chest or i guess a night table probably
probably not enough
um oh this is interesting um from super
chat have you seen any similarities in
the tribalist left
versus the tribalist religious community
in this case talking about mormons yeah
yeah absolutely and that's what i'm
saying about the moral system stuff i
think that anytime there is sort of this
community that is organized around
values morality there is the possibility
not always it's not to say we shouldn't
organize around our values we should but
there it lends itself to the possibility
of becoming sort of zealous
um and the question for me is how to
keep that in check the tribalism
not so much i would say in terms of the
moralizing
stuff like i don't know that religion is
my experience of religion was tribalist
necessarily uh would you be willing this
is super chat would you be willing to
talk to feminists like christina hoff
summers who critique third wave feminism
yeah
i would love to hope to i talked to a
feminist who
has a lot of things to say about third
wave feminism yesterday on my channel
yeah oh okay great well if you ever want
to do that not that you need me for it
but i'd be i'd love to facilitate that
conversation and i'll just be fine i'll
just tee it up and you can sit right
there and she'll sit here i adore
christina um okay
um
from patreon do you think
traditional political distinctions even
make sense anymore how would you define
yourself and who did you vote for in
2016 and why so they're asking a lot
there you said you're liberal before
yeah which i think you mean in in sort
of the way that i describe liberalism
which is
classical liberal and you believe in the
individual and
yeah or what does liberalism mean to you
i get really confused about all the
terms because people use them
differently so when it gets into like
the people who know a lot about poli-sci
i'm like i'm not really sure what the
right word is right
and you've got enough going on with
words yeah there's some word stuff
there's enough ways for people to
distort what i'm saying or thinking
without waiting into that but all right
so without getting caught in the words
if you were to describe yourself
politically like yeah where would you
sort of well i'm i i'm definitely like a
left i'd say i'm like a leftist
libertarian-leaning pro-tax
libertarian-ish
like i think businesses should be
regulated
and i think that individual freedoms
should be very very highly protected
first amendment very very very important
um
yeah i mean i'm not sure how to really
capture all my political thoughts
without going into each issue and how i
see it yeah well it's funny the way you
describe that because people always say
well how could you be a left libertarian
but i think you kind of hit it there
that you're for the maximum individual
freedom but you want some controls over
corporations and yes over business and
um
yeah i mean i i believe like there
should be business regulation but not
necessarily like personal regulation all
right fair enough
i've had a lot of libertarians on here
who would disagree with you on that but
that's what that's what it's all about
i'm still figuring it out and i don't
know if that's the most articulate way
of putting it but and that's just the
way they think so yeah it's all good
i mean
what i'm saying is i could probably be
convinced there's
more to this story
fair enough uh from patreon uh your
story sounds a whole lot like cassie j's
saga too uh have you talked to cassie or
watched the red pill are you familiar
with that movie yeah i did watch it um i
haven't talked to cassie though
and uh did it hit you i mean that's
actually why i asked you the men's
rights question oh right did that
movie hit you like in in any way i was
already aware of all that stuff and
already like in that camp i think it's
[ __ ] the feminists are shutting down
men's rights conversations and
protesting i mean they can protest
that's freedom of speech but shutting it
down like the fire alarms and all that
kind of stuff is not okay
and i've always felt that men um you
know are not discussed enough in the
conversation about abuse
i don't know as much about the like
court
the legal side of things
like custody yeah i don't know as much
about that it's a little removed from my
world
but i'm still learning more about it
um but yeah i mean i thought it was a
good a good documentary and i think that
people should
watch it even if they strongly disagree
with what she's going to say yeah
from super chat lacey based on your view
on trans issues what do you think about
parents pushing transgenderism
onto their children like in canada with
the genderless baby so i did you see
this story it was just in the last
couple days i guess the parents aren't
assigning a gender or something i i
didn't even read the article it was just
something that got i'm not familiar
yeah fair enough um lacey do you plan on
or do you want to speak to jordan
peterson
yeah people keep asking me that you
absolutely should i'd be happy to help
facilitate that one with me or without
that would that would be i want to
become more familiar with him and
christina's work first and i've been
buried
lately so for me like those
conversations aren't going to happen
immediately but they will happen i just
i like to know who i'm talking to first
you mean you want to know a little
something before you jump into the
conversation and really try to i want to
have like a baseline understanding of
their perspectives before i so they
don't have to rehash the basics with me
yeah uh lisey what's your opinion on the
1482
937.5 pronouns being shoved down
people's throats nowadays i was like
where is this going
i'm very impressed i can read so many
numbers in one shot with all the
pronouns i think that language is meant
to be pragmatic it's most it's meant to
communicate you know a lot of
information quickly so i take a more i
understand for me in a sex ed classroom
or in any of these contexts that i work
with individuals and teenagers i will
use whatever words they want um i don't
care how silly anyone thinks it is i
will defend it to the grave that when
you're in an individual context where
someone needs to feel respected you know
i'll use whatever words you need all
right and don't get mad at me if i mess
it up right because that's where it gets
like because i might mess it up but in
terms of like legally i don't think that
makes very much sense yeah which is a
little bit of what jordan peterson is
dealing with up in canada which is why i
think you guys would have agreed right
conversation
um hey lacey this is patreon uh what are
your thoughts on porn healthy or harmful
somewhere in between
um
a
very context dependent very very context
dependent i think that there are healthy
ways to
use porn there are healthy ways to
incorporate it into a relationship if
both people want to that needs to be
like a mutual thing
but i think there are unhealthy ways to
use it i think some porn can be you know
my my main concern with porn is that i
hear from 10 year olds and 11 year olds
who are seeing hardcore pornography as
their first experience with sex
you know that's the that's the first sex
ed they get that's not
porn's fault necessarily it's like a lot
of things and i think one of the biggest
things is that we don't have like real
conversations about sex with young
people in this country to equip them to
deal with things like porn to deal with
things like sexting or you know even
just basic relationship stuff so the
porn sort of exacerbates a problem in
the sex ed world that's already there um
and i'm anti-censorship so i say make
whatever porn you want yeah what about
the access to it like i remember when i
was 14 or something like to get access
to a magazine or something was
impossible you know daisy was like the
holy grail versus now anyone can turn on
their computer that's the thing right
literal children you know eight and
nine-year-olds i think there was i can't
remember the statistic but an alarming
number of nine-year-olds are finding
hardcore pornography and yeah i worry
about that and then i've also talked to
a lot of men who because
of the way that
what we think this is sort of
controversial science still but you know
we have this increasing increasing
threshold in the brain you know are we
sort of desensitizing ourselves to the
more common sexual experiences that
people have because of this highly
stimulating like super super stimulating
right imagery if you see super
stimulating stuff all the time
does everything else sort of you mean we
can't do all that [ __ ] that we see in
porn all the time we can't get into
every one of those positions you could
try you can try
i'm not gonna stop you i'm getting too
old for all that all right here we go
um
oh this is from phil defranco uh how
responsible do you think online creators
are for what their audiences say or do
to people that they talk about and why
that's a great question that i think we
all kind of deal with yeah yeah i think
i think that's a big problem um
i don't know i'm still trying to figure
that out i think that you know creators
do have some sort of an obligation to
discourage it like if you see a angry
mob forming because you're upset about
something and you share that with the
world and then people you know the
frothy mouths come out it is time to say
something be like yo calm down like
let's all bring it down a notch because
you are the you're sort of a leader in
the community right so if you see the
community getting a little crazy maybe
say something about it but ultimately
it's not the crea it's not my
responsibility what people in my
audience do it's not carl's
responsibility what people in his
audience do like it wouldn't be fair for
me to be like this is your fault like
you can be as angry as you want online
and that's the thing where i disagree
with feminists it's like well you need
to tone down your rhetoric or you need
to chill out because you're making
people mad it's like well you know
that's a slippery slope because a lot of
things make people mad now yeah i'm
curious when your channel was really
growing like i've noticed that my
audience especially on on youtube when
my channel was smaller like the comments
were a lot cleaner and on point and
things like that yeah then then we hit
some threshold that i think most
channels grow most hit but then it
started getting bananas and if and if
right now we were to look at the live
chat of course it's completely insane
yeah and by the way if everyone knows
i'm a free speech absolutist they can
all say whatever they want to know
do you happen to remember a moment when
like it went from like oh these are my
core people following me to now like
there's something else going on here
well
yeah i mean i think any time i've caught
the ire of the wider internet outside of
my community it's become a little bit
crazy and that's the other thing too is
like even if you people who watch you
are doing crazy stuff they're not
necessarily people who are gonna listen
to you who are who are watching you
after that you know it's just like a big
it's a big mess yeah so it's i think
it's unfair for people to claim that
this is your
fault if people online do crazy stuff
yeah um
so i'm getting a couple comments in here
because i just mentioned phil did that
you maybe called him alt-right once
i've never called phil all right
all right so i'm not even sure unless i
was also very drunk and forgot that too
it's always a possibility okay i gotta
stop the drug tweeting okay there you go
this is the proof that i'm reading all
this stuff live all right let's jump
back to uh
to patreon uh oh i love this question um
lacey what do you think about the war on
context and satire that's going on in
our culture now it's no coincidence that
you're laughing a lot more with your new
friends i completely agree with that and
one of the reasons that i've been so
frustrated with the left is they've
become so hysterical that they're not
funny anymore comics used to be
yeah yeah they're laughing what do you
think about that um what does that mean
though like what's the real question
there like i think the context is well
that i think that
i guess that the hysteria and the war on
words and political correctness has now
made it so that people are afraid to
laugh as you said before that even if
you're 100
for
trans people but you're you can still be
afraid to
make a joke that then you know they pin
you yeah no i think that that is a side
effect of this problem that is a that's
actually a big side effect because
people need to laugh people need to be
relaxed and have a good time and even if
they say something that's like a little
bit [ __ ] up stop acting like that's
causing genocide you know like it's not
we we go from zero to a thousand like so
quick and it's like look i agree that
jokes like something i've talked about a
lot is rape jokes right i agree that
there's sort of this insidious thing
that can underlie some
jokes like like
jokes that are like haha you got raped
you know for me as someone who has
experienced sexual violence it makes me
uncomfortable i don't think that people
should not be able to say rape jokes or
that they can never be funny i just
think you know one don't expect everyone
to laugh all the time but also let's
lighten up a little bit because
sometimes the comedy can be healing you
know purpose of coming i mean that is
literally the purpose of comedy uh sex
question from uh super chat what do you
think of men who would identify as
straight who are attracted to people who
cross stress so just to be clear for
people that's not transgender people
just wearing different clothes right
yeah so it's interesting that they were
to people who cross-dress so that means
he might be attracted to a man who's
dressing like a woman or a woman who's
dressing like a man what about it cool
i mean get it yeah go get it go get it
out of town yeah
um okay
uh hey lacey any tips on dealing with
the close-mindedness on campus i'd love
to hear you and dave come speak at my
school together let us know know what
school it is and maybe we can set that
up um do you do you do some stuff at
schools right i've done a lot yeah at
schools that was my life for the last
five years that's you know how i've paid
my bills and stuff which is why i need
to find a job now
um did you see a change in the five
years oh yes yes oh yes i'd say the
campuses were like
one of the main places that i started to
see a lot of this stuff
campus and online okay online is the
main place i should correct that but
campus says yes you know there's um a
really high level of sensitivity and it
made me really nervous to like say
anything and do something wrong i was
some of these schools that i've walked
into that have very very ultra left
reputations
have been terrifying and they've some of
these students have treated me like dog
[ __ ] like abs and it's like wow
i'm here like talking about the things
we both care about you know these
students have attacked me just like
crazy stuff um
i i
am worried about that because academia
is a place to question it's a it's a
place to really be pressed you know
to really be pushed on you know how you
see things to really learn how to think
that's what college is about it's not
about what you learn it's about learning
how to critically evaluate information
you learn how to do research you learn
how to argue with different ideas you
hear you read different philosophers and
things that are wild and out there and
you learn how to think about you know
evaluate what they're saying
if we don't do that at academia in
academia anymore if that's discouraged
in some way because we can't hear a
speaker because
might hurt some feelings might be
controversial if that isn't happening
anymore what the hell is the point of
going to college you know like
and i'm not i don't think this is like a
really widespread problem like we got i
think this is spreading though
there's the little seeds yeah oh i think
i think it's gone past the seed i mean
my
i might be a little bit like
not
quite i don't see it quite the same way
as you i because my experience is that a
lot of the schools that i go to don't
care yeah like i'd say it's like a 80 20
split like most of the schools i've been
to it's fine whatever you know but 20
are just like
and maybe that's just the identity of
the school you know if you want to go to
ultra conservative or ultra liberal
school go right ahead is it the best
education for you probably not yeah but
that's your decision and yet in a
bizarre twist you know a school like
evergreen state that's a lefty lefty
lefty school yeah is now having all of
these free speech problems and racial
problems he prepared for it to eat it so
right
exactly there you go i think you
answered this but it's uh but it's very
pointed here already uh do you this is
super chat do you regret the [ __ ] white
america trump tweet do you actually
regret it no yeah okay no i don't regret
i mean i think i don't think anybody
should like regret things they say
unless it causes
violence
and all i did was hurt feelings you
drunkenly tweeted
[ __ ] your feelings
there you go uh
super chat what is your opinion when
non-black people use the n-word
um i am
personally i
don't like it i don't tell people what
to say if we're in a context where it's
like inappropriate i will say something
you know because sometimes it's not
appropriate i'm not a fan of the n word
you know i just am not i don't think
it's like a a good nice word but look
say whatever the [ __ ] you want i don't
care
i'm with you sister uh patreon have you
looked into the effect hormonal
contraceptives have on the brain slash
behavior i feel like it's something
which isn't talked about enough and
there aren't many studies on it either
except in the field of evolutionary
psychology this one's going a little
above my pay grade what
i'm not sure exactly what they're
referring to but we already know that
hormonal birth control isn't the
healthiest greatest thing for most
people for some people it treats medical
conditions and it does prevent pregnancy
um so there's that but you know there
are always these are medications you
know they're imperfect when they say
hormonal is that like that's like the
pill
well there's the pill and there's the
patch and there's the ring and you know
there's lots of different hormonal types
most are hormonal actually we got like
the copper iud it's non-hormonal condoms
are non-hormonal
fertility awareness is not hormonal
what do you think patreon again what do
you think about teaching
of identity is sexual gender racial in
public classrooms before high school
that's interesting because a lot of the
stuff that you talk about
it's kind of like where is the moment
where it's right to talk about it wait
talk about identities
the question oh there we go what do you
think about the teaching of identities
meaning teaching about sexual identity
or gender identity et cetera in public
classrooms before high school so
basically i think asking when is it okay
to really
take a young person and talk about this
stuff about success that might confuse
them well i guess sexual identity gender
identity i think that's a little more
specific than just sex ed okay okay like
well i would see that as couched within
sex ed like in sex ed we talk about
people who are gay and people who are
trans right um i would say middle school
is a good time um but the key is not to
one of the things that i've seen
rightful panic happen um on the more
right side of the right politically
right side of things is like the
imposition of like suggesting to kids
that you are this like
that's
where i think the real fear comes from
and good sex ed is not
it's not that at all it's just like hey
some people are gay you know they have
dicks and they like dicks and some
people are you know straight and they
you know have penises and vaginas yay
and some people are trans this is just a
thing so when you see someone who's
holding hands with a man in public don't
freak out i have a great idea for a
youtube video that you have to do you
need to do a video of something like
like the sex ed teacher who's over it
like just like who has said this [ __ ] so
much that it's like yes some people have
dicks and they are like dicks and she
likes vaginas what do you want me to do
like just over it you know i feel like
i've been over it since i was like 15.
like whatever just let people live but
that
in a way it's the kind of funny thing of
of what you do because these these
issues and there's always going to be
new young people that need to learn
about these things you can only find x
amount of new ways to say them and i
mean i'll just keep saying it a lot of
what i say is just saying the same thing
over and over and over again that's fine
that's part of educating uh this is
super chat with the rolling stone
uh uva rape scandal has your position on
listen and believe
change with regards to the rape
accusations so i suspect maybe you did a
video that you were you you did believe
it at first which most people did not
the not the uva well
the the that was like the crazy rolling
st i think i'm thinking of the right
thing like there was the story that the
rolling stone journal i think there was
like some journalistic ethics issues
there they had like inserted some their
i don't know if i'm remembering this
right well i think that if i'm not
mistaken the rolling stone when i think
was was duke university and it turned
out not to have happened
um but all right without different maybe
i don't know okay okay
all right so for the record since we're
a little unclear exactly but has your
position on listen and believe change
regards to rape accusations so let's
just do it at the broader um i'd say
generally not but i will acknowledge
that there is more
nuance to these issues i just think it's
really
difficult to figure out how to navigate
all of that
but i do think in general
when someone comes forward about sexual
assault it's not my place to doubt
question or or probe them you know and
be the arbiter of their of the truth
um as a crisis counselor you know
someone who's worked in rape crisis
counseling centers and these kinds of
things we listen and we believe what
they're saying we do what we can to
support them
of course due process is very important
of course you know all these things that
are in place to ensure the delivery of
justice in our system should be there
you know those are very important
protections against misuse of the system
and i think that it should be a
punishable crime to lie about these
things especially if you ruin someone's
reputation yeah and in the day and age
of twitter and everything else that that
is a huge piece of this right uh even
some of these kids that i don't think
their intentions are that bad they
accidentally
say oh this guy did this you know like i
don't know maybe i'm giving them a
little sometimes they go to the internet
yeah or they
because they don't know where else to go
it's really complicated you know it's
really complicated stuff but of course
these issues are always you know there's
many
there's many things to consider
and i try to do that the best i can
without being an [ __ ] to rape
survivors you know fair enough uh super
chat do you think that the similar
suicide rates for pre-op
and post uh and post-op trans people
indicate that perhaps such methods of
therapy are not effective or beneficial
is that true
so i can't swear that the that the rates
are true right
but you're not google date i'm not
google here if that is true
i would say that suggests that maybe
they there does need to be better
treatment or i don't know that's
complicated i'm not sure how i feel
about that i need to think on it all
right fair enough uh super chat lacey i
wanted to get your impression of the
huffington post article about you
written by kelsey ingram by the way
loved your bdsm sex ed vid so i don't
know what the article's referring to do
you have no there's honestly been so
many hit pieces about me at this point
calling me an alt-right nazi calling me
a white supremist calling me a
transphobe who hates black people like
every every liberal
like every little liberal hammer that
could be nailed it has been done so
isn't it funny how you become numb to
that stuff literally the first thing i
saw when i looked at my phone this
morning was a good friend of mine who's
been a guest on the show said oh this
guy who we both know wrote a hit piece
about you this morning
and he didn't link me to it and i was
like whatever it is i don't care yeah i
mean why would i care what some randos
on the internet have to say
about what i have to do obviously if you
think that's true you're not paying any
attention to what i'm saying or doing at
all and in that case you're not educated
you're ignorant you're hate-mongering
and i don't care what you think
she's on it uh lacey do you think it's
immoral to lie about your biological sex
to potential sexual partners
if you're a post-op transsexual
um to lie about so you're a post-op
transsexual meaning you've transitioned
from let's say a man to a woman
and now you're the the man let's say
it's a heterosexual relationship the man
now thinks that
you were always all right i'm about my
language is not good you were always a
woman or what would be the better way to
say that right the man sees you as
another man maybe oh wait post-op yeah
they said post-op
so are we talking about like genital
reconstruction well i guess the the
thrust of it was so many things if you
if you have fully transitioned and you
meet someone
i guess the question really is do you
have to tell them right if if you buy
all other measures
right woman or whatever i i don't think
the question is do you have to tell them
it's just like what does good
communication about our sexual histories
look like and about who we are you know
i don't think there's there should
necessarily be like a law like you need
to tell me you know because it's like
why
i don't i don't know that i see the real
harm that that causes besides someone
having
like i don't know
being uncomfortable with it i guess
right but we should not we should tell
things
before you have sex with someone you
should tell them the things that may
potentially make them uncomfortable
that's sort of my
policy and that all people should be
talking about stuff if you have had any
stis before or you know maybe you're
into something that's a little weird
don't just spring it on me like tell me
first all those things should be talked
about first and i think that if we
create a world where it's more
acceptable for trans people it's more
acceptable for them to move through the
world and be seen as legitimate valid
human beings it'll be easier to talk
about because you're not scared of
someone having violently attacking you
because you they are transphobic and
that's what transphobia is right right
is the violent attacks um because you
feel like you have been
threatened by their existence yeah did
you watch uh transparent by any chance
yes so i just watched it over the last
couple months i'm not caught up on it by
the way okay then i don't want to say
anything
but i think there's so much that when
you by the time you get to the end
you're gonna be like holy cow it's so
related to your story in a way because
there's so much because they do turn
they don't it's not a sjw fest which you
when i started watching it i was like oh
i'm going to end up hating this because
they're going to be pushing all this
stuff and all the language stuff they
don't they actually make fun of a lot of
the hysterics so that's a good pitch to
finish it up that's all i will say got
my netflix outline ah my buddy that guy
t he says hi babes do you believe that
the hyper sexualization slash
objectification of women in hip-hop
to be sex-positive or sex-negative
um
i think that's a difficult
question
i think it sort of depends on i think
some women
kind of feel like that like to feel sexy
in those contacts or whatever
um that and that's fine so i would say
that's sex positive i think what sex
negative is if the only place for women
in hip-hop is to be a sexy background
dancer right like if we have all the
hip-hop and it's always like the dude at
the center and then sexy ladies dancing
around him
that's where
you know the problem lies because
obviously not every single woman is
going to
want to be a backup dancer she might
want to be the
rapper too yeah
have you changed your stance on the wage
gap given the overwhelming evidence
pointing towards perfectly reasonable
and nonsense non-sexist systemic or
otherwise factors yes
that's a great place for you to talk to
christina off summers yeah who really
opened my eyes to that stuff she does
probably the best work that i've seen on
that yeah i've i've done more digging
into the i still think i
the research still shows a wage gap but
it does show that there is a much more
complicated picture than the sort of 77
cents to a dollar line
okay uh this is super chat this one this
one seems to be going deep from a
biological perspective how to intersex
conditions invalidate the sex binary
classifications any more than
trisomy 21 invalidates homo sapien
classification a disorder doesn't do
that i have to be 100 honest i'm not
sure what i know they're talking can you
clean that up yes so i think they're
asking they're saying intersex is not a
third sex you know you have the you have
sex it's these two poles you have male
and female and intersex doesn't say that
there's not a sex binary any more than
um i think tris is it down syndrome any
more than like different uh conditions
say something about humans
uh
what was the end of that question
uh any more than trisomy 21 invalidates
quote homo sapien classification oh a
disorder system 21 is a different
disorder i'm not sure okay but the point
is how is
how does intersex say there's not a sex
binary i'm not saying there isn't a sex
binary i just think that even binaries
have are on spectrums it is a binary but
there's also like some in between area
right like man and woman or male and
female for instance
they are most people fall into these
categories but there are some people who
are not squarely one or the other that's
just the reality of it yeah so while sex
is generally a binary
there are exceptions to the rule and
that doesn't mean that sex isn't
generally a binary it just means that
there are exceptions to the rule there
seems to be a theme here about tolerance
and exceptions to rules and like it's
okay life is more complicated than we
like to think of it there you go
patreon how does lacey feel about all
the research that shows a clear
relationship between people who engage
in promiscuous premarital sex and
co-habitation are far more likely
divorced as adults is there no place in
education for morality particularly sex
education
do you have no obligation to modify your
advice if it's doing harm
that that's kind of interesting i don't
know that there is that that is the
research and if it is we have to
contextualize that research people are
getting divorced born now period like
when women earned the right to initiate
a divorce few decades ago divorces went
way up you know there's all these things
that affect that and i think people see
marriage as less
sacred than they may have before but
people are more willing to prioritize
their happiness they're not in a
relationship with someone that they
that they like
they get divorced
and the people who cohabitate in this in
this instance they've been together for
a while they may eventually realize that
they're not you know the ones who
cohabitate are probably more likely to
split up if they're not happy they
cohabitate first they've already been
together for a while it makes sense that
they might have higher divorce rates
that doesn't mean it's because they're
morally failing in my opinion i just
think that's a overly simplistic way of
thinking of it um whereas i would see it
as well people are just doing what they
want more and that's good that's good uh
you got 15 more minutes in yeah yeah all
right 15 more minutes we're going to
bludgeon you with more questions and
then we're going to do a we're going to
do a rapid fire just for for patrons
after that real quick uh what is your
opinion about the intersection between
religion and feminism for example the
rise of mormon feminists such as laurel
thatcher ulrich joanne uh jonah brooks
et cetera would you talk to them yes i
would talk to them i think religion
needs feminism badly
religion is like abrahamic religion i
should specify abrahamic religion is
very patriarchal if we want to talk
about patriarchy right
feminists want to complain about a
patriarchy yeah that is it that is
literally it women are not allowed to be
leaders know your place can't talk to
god all this stuff so i would say
do it
bring the feminism to religion it really
needs it
uh super chat should we respect the idea
identity of the trans abled who identify
as someone with less limbs and often
seek to [ __ ] themselves so i know
that that sort of sounds crazy but there
is some movement have you heard about
this of movement of people that want to
be trans abled so that they've gone out
of their way to to do things to their
bodies so that uh they've harmed
themselves have you heard it about that
sounds really intense yeah i i've seen
it yeah yeah yeah um i don't doubt that
it's a thing i know like trans age is a
thing transracial is a thing now
uh the the trans question is really
interesting but i don't know about the
transable
stuff all right fair enough uh super
chat how do we win the fight for the
future of the left will you support
bernie sanders in rejecting identity
politics it's interesting because i i
think he really traded in them then
after the election suddenly said we need
to stop doing that yeah but that aside
what do you think about fixing the left
do you think now that you've so seen
what's going on do you think that's a
reclamation project that's real does
something new need to jump out of it the
identity politics stuff well the left in
general yeah do you think it's something
that can be fixed all these things that
we seem wrong with it or does something
new have to come or
do people have to move more to the
center i don't know
i feel very lost in it i don't really
know what can
make liberalism liberal again um
[ __ ] yeah
let me know if you have answers because
i sure as hell don't
lacey what are your thoughts on antifa
slash black block and their behaviors
after the inauguration and during events
at universities in socal so these guys
who dress like cobra soldiers and
they're burning [ __ ] and somehow they're
the not fascists yeah i'm not a fan of
antifa
it's not my it's not my bag i think that
anybody who uses violence is you know a
problem
especially when it's violence because of
just things that people think or say
yeah like it's literally it's not
violence that you're not retaliating to
and tifa isn't retaliating to what milo
yiannopoulos did they were retaliating
to what he said yeah and they're also
retaliating by burning a third-party
thing yeah like burning down starbucks
isn't hurting milo
you're actually helping milo yeah and
also giving my alma mater a bad name
berkeley it's the center of the free
speech movement like it has such a
legacy in a history and they've thrown
the students under the bus i would say
what years were you at berkeley
i graduated in 2011.
did you see the underpinnings of what's
going on there now
berkeley has always had a strong history
of protests you know it's very much a
part of student life if you have a
problem or you want to talk about
politics we protest and it's beautiful
it's like you know you get together on a
weekend and you protest whatever you
know but the the problem i think now is
that people are using berkeley as a sort
of site of their own political like
outside people are coming to berkeley
and are using it as a uh
i don't know
they're using it to their advantage when
the students
students don't support that [ __ ] they
don't want their university torn up any
more than anyone else does you know
nobody wants to be blocked off of the
whole quad because some [ __ ] you
know
through
they cause a lot of graffiti and damage
yeah i was people have done that people
did that when i was there the anti-fuck
people who live in oakland the city over
they come over to berkeley they do the
[ __ ] and it always pissed the students
off nobody ever liked that stuff we're
peaceful protesters at berkeley why
didn't the university crack down more in
general on the on antibiotics yeah when
they come on to campus i mean there's
campus security we're like why do they
allow them there i don't know you know
or even the police side sometimes you
see these people burning things cops
standing right in front of them and it's
like why aren't you guys doing something
i don't is that true because i feel like
the cops in berkeley are pretty
proactive um but they also are very like
lenient they let people do like they
fine line between proactive and lenient
you know i mean look at it this way like
they see sometimes they'd see burning a
flag or starting fires as free speech
like that is
the berkeley free speech like it is very
very lenient and people see that as
other cops aren't doing anything the
university isn't doing anything it's
like well no we just
think they have a right to when it
starts to hurt people
that's where [ __ ] goes down fair enough
um
do you think that oh this is good do you
think you'll make amends with any other
youtubers the way you did with sargon
um
i'm trying to think of who yeah i'm sure
i'm sure there are a few people that i'd
still like to make amends with
all right i like that um
there's been a few questions that sort
of have basically said something to the
effect of is there anyone that you
wouldn't talk to
no
we'll talk to anyone
and see what happens
i like it all right
one of the most insulting things to say
to another guy is calling them gay most
men also refuse to watch gay porn does
that mean that there is an unconscious
rejection to homosexuality that won't
change
that's interesting because those are two
very different things yeah
because i feel like on the first part of
that question is talking about
some some homophobia right like right uh
gay stuff is bad don't do gay [ __ ] right
yeah and then the other side of it what
was the second part of the question well
about watching porn most men also refuse
to watch gay people right and that's
like is does everyone have homosexuality
deep down within them and it's like no
right like these are some people are gay
some people are straight
that's why the the transphobia in the
bedroom stuff is so silly because it's
like you're gay or you're straight or
whatever and like there is a little
fluidity there and people sort of
discover themselves as they age and have
new experiences but
yeah i mean i don't think that's like a
deep-seated
truth about homosexuality so much as it
is a deep-seated truth about sexuality
period yeah have you ever done anything
on sort of the way the gay community has
changed because i've seen a huge shift
in in the gay community just in in the
last you know i came out i came out late
in like my mid to late 20s i'm 41 now
and when the gay community when i first
was sort of going to gay bars and things
like it was all about this like over the
top political incorrectness like
craziness all the drag queens i never
liked any of it i always thought because
i thought drag queens were basically bad
comedians and i was doing stand-up so
like i never was into that
but like the political incorrectness and
saying crazy [ __ ] and that was
encouraging and [ __ ] it was encouraged
and now it's very much kind of fall in
lockstep believe what we believe
politically that's so crazy
there was a horrific article written in
about six months ago written in either
the advocate or one of those things
about how peter thiel is not really gay
because he doesn't fall into our
political beliefs that it's a that it's
somehow a political ideology and not you
know how do these people not see their
own hypocrisy yeah you got your gay card
revoked for being conservative that's
crazy isn't that something but that's
real i mean that's really real i mean
i've been talking to some older trans
people who are like in their 40s and 50s
and it's really interesting because you
know the the trans movement has evolved
in a similar way it sounds like to the
game i mean they're kind of side by side
um where you know people have their
feeling is people's feelings are hurt
way too easily it's too politically
correct now it used to be about [ __ ]
the system now you become the system
which is interesting you know and we
always look back and romanticize things
so those people in their 40s and 50s
probably had to live through some pretty
horrible [ __ ] i'm sure yeah but like
life is good now what are you
complaining about isn't that something
it tells you about why the arc of
justice oh this is a good one because i
get some [ __ ] on my stance for it uh and
i have no idea what your thoughts are do
you think a bakery should be forced to
bake a gay wedding cake for a same-sex
wedding even if they believe it is
against their religious beliefs
so
i don't know how i feel about it exactly
but my initial you know i thought about
a lot my initial thing is why would you
want to give money to people who are are
like don't recognize your union you know
who are [ __ ] now
you know just go to a different bakery
but like we live in la like there's 9
million bakeries right you have a lot of
choices so you can vote with your
dollars in a sense where i get a little
bit
more confused or conflicted is maybe
there's only one bakery in your whole
town that makes wedding cakes and now
because you're gay you can't have a
wedding cake
you know
yeah so i understand that line of
thinking i i don't agree with it because
i know it sucks i've said this a
thousand times i know it sucks yeah but
either go to the town over or order a
cake on amazon or leave that town these
are all hard choices i don't say these
things with any
degree of cards this is the way it
should be or any of that but i think ex
forcing a private company to do
something
just which then extends the state power
over a private business i just
i i just personally wouldn't want that i
know it sucks it's not fun yeah people
give me [ __ ] for it but i just don't
think
we live in a different time the uh this
isn't 1940 where you know that may have
been the only baker within 50 miles and
even if you live in a remote place
amazon does deliver everywhere and just
more excuses for stay power uh this is
somewhere where i get a point i
definitely veer a little more
libertarian on that but i understand the
good intentions by the way of the people
that don't agree with me on that yeah
yeah i know that's a fair point i'll
have to think about that all right we'll
do this again and you can give me a
fully thought out answer
um
super chat given that we're a sexually
dimorphic species how likely do you
think it is that the remaining
achievement gap between men and women is
biological also how many shots did you
do over the break we didn't do any shots
it's a little it's a little early in the
day and i have two more shows right yeah
yeah i don't believe you
and i i don't have i don't have very
good experiences being too loose-lipped
so
um you know we'll do shots
another time over dinner or something
yeah we should on camera we should when
you don't have a super busy day that
would be great
um sorry
so the question was given that we're a
sexually dimorphic uh species how likely
do you think that the remaining
achievement gap between men and women is
actually biological and i know this can
be pretty controversial to some people i
i am of the the reason why i'm a
feminist is i am of the opinion that you
know while men and women do have
differences males and females i should
say do have biological differences that
can that lend themselves to slightly
different behavior with testosterone uh
being slightly more aggressive and you
know
the
oxytocin in the bonding with the baby
being the more nurturing hormones things
like that i do think that there are a
lot of things that are being a lot of
inequalities for men and women that are
being caused by our social environment
so i don't think we're there yet and the
reason i believe that is because when
you look at under other countries it's
different which to me says this isn't
just like because biology is across the
world right so if we can observe a
difference in a different culture that
means it's not biological that means
that it is caused by the culture and the
environment yeah all right one more one
more here we go one more and i think
this sort of will encapsulate a lot of
things we've been talking about this is
from patreon why is third wave feminism
turned into this devastating tsunami of
unreason why has it so successfully
taken over the pc media discourse the
way that it has and how do we fight the
unreason and get back to sanity this is
hurting young people especially we've
sort of talked this out already but just
this whole thing the way feminism
relates to media relates to online and
everything uh you just give me your best
antidotes like that the best way to fix
it the best way that well just for you
personally what is your best way of
fighting it for someone else that's
seeing that right i think feminism
feminists and leftists need to reclaim
their causes
and
need to stand up to people who are
trying to bastardize and distort what
we're actually fighting for who are
using shame censorship anti-science
manipulation
bullying all this kind of [ __ ] to
push a political a radical political
agenda i think people who are not down
with those kinds of politics need to
step up and say something about it even
though it's scary you might lose friends
you might you know have to make sure
you're in a place to deal with it just
like my own story make sure you can deal
with it but do it because
look what's happening yeah it's this is
not gonna help
liberalism this is not gonna help
feminists i don't care what they say i
do not see this helping anyone all i see
is alienation people getting angry and
hostile to things they actually do
support
all of the antis every anti-feminist
that i've talked to so far
agrees with me on this basic [ __ ] about
social issues they agree on the you know
the trans stuff they agree with me on
gay rights they agree with me and that's
not to say everyone will
but a lot of people this is just to say
a lot of these outspoken figureheads are
turning against this [ __ ] and in the
process
the real base causes what we're fighting
for is being lost
and that's why i felt like i had to say
something ultimately is because holy
[ __ ]
all of these people who were all in this
together are now fighting over things
because of these crazies we gotta
distance ourselves from that
it's gotten too out of control for a lot
of reasons but
i would my advice is to say something be
polite be
respectful be willing to question that
you could be wrong be willing to check
your privilege all right
but at the end of the day you know stand
up for what is good and right and what
will make the actually make this world a
better place
well that seems like a pretty perfect
ending i thoroughly enjoyed these two
hours
yeah well me too and i knew that i was
going to enjoy it but i love seeing
someone that that the personal part of
this matches up with the public part and
someone that's that's on there that's on
their own adventure too that's what it's
all about and
can show some vulnerability and
want to figure out uh what the best way
to go forward is we'll do five more
minutes just for patrons okay and uh
thank you so much you guys know where to
find her on youtube already so that
would be even silly for me to do any
more pimping than that thank you to
lacey and uh we are going to be live i
got a crazy day today we are going to be
live with eric weinstein one of my good
buddies and probably the smartest guy i
know we're doing that at i believe it's
1 30 p.m
uh pacific
eastern 1 30 p.m eastern
1 30 30 1 30 pacific sorry i gotta
create 1 30 p.m pacific i'm live with
eric weinstein uh right here i'm also
interviewing uh economist pio mullaney
later today but that's going to be up in
a couple weeks and uh thank you guys for
watching this and uh more with lacey for
patrons only in just a sec
[Music]